This is our town Saint Paul, Minnesota
USA. Located halfway between the equator
and the north pole with no large bodies of
water nearby to check extreme temperatures
and no protective mountain ranges to ward off heat
and cold saint paul lights have learned to live
with the distinct seasonal changes traditional
in a temperate climate winters here are cold with
plenty of ice and snow the clear bright days and
the thrill of winter sports more than compensate
for any inconvenience brought about by blustery
weather summers are marked by periods of bright
warm sun and cooling showers when we appreciate
our abundance of summer recreational facilities
to combat these extremes in climate we have
at our disposal a wide choice of clothing
for thousands of years man has
steadily improved upon his apparel
weaving sewing and inventing new fabrics to keep
his body free from the effects of heat and coal
through many centuries he relied on animal
skins and furs and cloth woven from living
fibers nowadays these age-old methods have
been supplemented by man-made synthetics it's
important that saint paul lights be accurately
informed about weather conditions newspapers radio
television and other communications make weather
reporting a part of their daily schedule everyone
young and old alike is interested in what the
weather will be it's a vital part of our lives for
weather forecasting tells us what to wear how to
dress this afternoon tonight or tomorrow morning
whether there'll be rain or snow is something
mother must know every day of the year
so the children will be prepared cold st
paul winters call for the warmest sweaters
coats and gloves to keep young bodies healthy
in and out of doors winter brings with it many
hazards which must be guarded against by
the best our clothing industry has to offer
comfortable lightweight garments designed to
provide freedom of movement and utmost warmth
saint paul's global position
at 40 degrees north latitude
creates our climate of extremes during the
winter we're tilted away from the sun and receive
only its reflected rays these long slanted rays
are not strong nor abundant enough to be absorbed
and we find ourselves with many months of
low temperatures and snow-covered streets
but adequate clothing permits us to enjoy
ourselves even in the midst of winter's grip
in summer we bear the direct rays of the
sun which cause our warmest temperatures
but being a people fond of the outdoors
we found ways to escape the heat of summer
present-day summer clothing is a far cry from
the swimsuits of 1910 in those days the body
was intended to be covered social behavior
cared little for comfort and clothing was not
designed with the wearer in mind activities of
all kinds were restricted by cumbersome styles
only during the last forty years or so have
people begun to enjoy the benefits of sensible
easy to wear clothing women especially had
always been subjected to the discomforts
of bustles long skirts heavy materials and
other constricting garments and accessories
these limited their freedom prevented an active
participation in the community kept them in the
home and away from healthy activities such as
sports which are today enjoyed by women of all
ages but women have always been
style conscious in pioneer saint
paul stores were stocked with the latest
fabrics and patterns from eastern cities
and the lady of the house could put her
ingenuity to work to fashion garments for
herself and for her family that would do justice
to folks in new york boston or philadelphia
when the demands of a conservative society
were silenced the bustle and long skirt were
replaced by the flapper who told the world
that she would participate in an active world
wearing clothes which allowed
her to do as much as a man
modern inventions have brought about the need for
suitable clothes although the enclosed comfortable
cars of today don't require special garb once upon
a time 20 miles an hour was a breathtaking speed
and high sitting open cars called for scarves
to keep wide brimmed hats from blowing away
and appropriate coats to keep the dust off starch
colors and mutton sleeves today choice of clothing
is dictated by purpose style and personal taste
ensuring high fashion with maximum efficiency
back in 1871 when our town was still a fledgling
city Gordon and Ferguson began clothing Saint
Paul folks with coats and robes made from the
warm weatherproof skins of wandering buffalo
Today in a modern plant the firm has progressed
from the manufacture of the rude garments of
frontier Minnesota to smart perfectly tailored
outdoor clothing for men women and boys
it's an interesting operation one which
requires skilled hands and skilled equipment
yards of material spread out on 75-foot tables
in layers up to eight inches high first come
under the sure hand of the cutter who guides
the whirling cutting machines along a pattern
all parts of a garment must come
from the same piece of material
and are shade marked by a ticketing
machine to keep them in order
the pattern is placed on top of
the stack but each layer of cloth
must be cut to exactly the same measurements
for proper fit when the garment is completed
these workers are masters of their trades
and though their tools save time and labor
only their steady hands and
eyes can assure a job well done
each operation contributes to the
overall perfection of fine tailoring
operators so only one portion
of a garment such as pockets
on machines which complete four to
five thousand stitches per minute
some machines are equipped with special
attachments which do binding and other
fancy stitching the stitching
room is a well-organized area
with materials moving from one operator to the
next each one adding her own particular skill to
create a piece of clothing more attractive and
serviceable than any homemade garment could be
quality control is maintained at all
times by inspections and measurements
which make sure that garments are
being finished to exact specifications
guarding the standards of fine workmanship
though the buffalo coat has passed from our
scene leather coats are still
made in substantial quantity
buttonholes are fashioned on automatic machines
which cut and stitch the holes to preset sizes
by the operator merely pressing
a pedal two or four hole buttons
are applied to the garment by a machine
which automatically stops after making 21
stitches some pressing is done between
manufacturing steps and all finished goods
receive a final pressing to assure proper shape
careful hanging further preserves the appearance
a fully staffed stock room receives the
finished merchandise and stores
it until needed to fill an order
a carefully devised system of
stock control simplifies the
assembly of orders by personnel of
the packing and shipping department
300 employees of gordon and ferguson use
their skill and experience to provide folks
from coast to coast with the quality of
field and stream and town outdoor clothing
local educational facilities provide many skilled
workers for the saint paul clothing industry
our town is prominent in this field and thousands
of folks find profitable employment
in all sorts of garment manufacturing
such public vocational schools offer comprehensive
training to young people in preparation for
work of this type students learn sewing machine
operation cutting layout and pattern work under
the instruction of skilled tradesmen with the
wholehearted cooperation of local clothing firms
clothing courses are also popular with adults
in special evening instruction programs
these attentive folks are using their leisure
hours to pick up pointers on home tailoring
learning how to design and
make clothes for their families
in either case the classes are informative
and constructive pupils practice under the
guidance of trained teachers following
lectures and practical demonstrations
courses range from beginner
classes to advanced study
selection of fabric pattern work and layout are
followed by instruction in machine operation
accessories have become an important part
of modern wardrobes and their selection and
proper use is demonstrated by experts besides
information gained in the classes people derive
enjoyment from discovering hidden abilities
and meeting new people as with youngsters
school offers older folks the opportunity to
expand both educational and social boundaries
the year's work culminates in a gala
fashion show and party at which garments
made by adult education pupils are modeled
everyone is anxious to see the results of
their classmates work and especially
to hear approval of their own creations
this is a critical audience made up of
students who learned well under expert guidance
all sorts of clothing is modeled
from sophisticated suits and dresses
to carefully made children's attire
pride and quality of workmanship
so lovingly imparted to each garment has its
reward in the spectator's enthusiastic applause
home sewing today is a large-scale
business woolen companies with wide
and varied stocks of fine fabric supply yard
goods to both home and professional tailors
st paul the center of the nation's winter
sports clothing industry is the site of many
garment and knitting mills the university of
minnesota agricultural college in saint paul
is one of the many public and private institutions
conducting research in textiles and in the care
and maintenance of clothing thorough studies are
made of the qualities of different kinds of fabric
one interesting experiment shows the
resistance of various materials to fading
a special machine is used to gauge the
degree of fading from exposure to life
another test is concerned with washability and
color fastness new synthetics are studied as
well as standard fabrics and findings are often
published and distributed as a public service
the amount of strain which fabrics will take
is also measured to determine their durability
strength is especially important in children's
clothes and in work garments for they undergo
hard use results of these strength experiments
often furnish the basis for recommending to
manufacturers as well as homemakers the fabrics
that will give satisfactory performance in use
the work in these laboratories is carried on under
exacting conditions humidity and temperature are
carefully watched to assure complete control and
a standard research environment using the most
modern equipment device scientists and trained
technicians put all their knowledge and skill to
work to assure folks in saint paul and throughout
the united states of better more practical apparel
a sizable portion of our family budget is spent
on clothing mom dad and the youngsters all have
separate wardrobes for nearly every season and
these clothes must be well taken care of modern
laundries and dry cleaning firms are important to
the proper clothing care their advanced equipment
and methods offer excellent protection to the life
and appearance of every kind of garment a complex
identification system enables workers to sort
finish garments for return to the proper owner
materials which cannot be washed are processed
by automatic machines which
clean with chemical solutions
stains are removed by the spotter an expert with
chemicals who must also recognize the type of
stain the presser uses steam equipment
to give each garment a perfect finish
additional touching up is done with a hand iron
every piece is given a thorough inspection to see
that spots have been removed that minor repairs
have been made and that a proper pressing
job has been done unsatisfactory garments
are sent back for reprocessing finally protective
bags or wrappings are applied for safe delivery
when ready to wear our clothes
present a sparkling new appearance
testimony to the skill and efficiency of
modern dry cleaning and laundering methods
proper care and pride of clothing are important
parts of a child's education in saint paul homes
and schools these points are stressed to
encourage an interest in good appearance
good grooming and personal care always
mark the well-dressed man or woman
privately owned schools show girls and
women the way to an attractive appearance
courses include makeup instruction
by professional beauty experts
every phase of personal care is
covered in comprehensive courses
many women attend to learn more about
themselves how to dress the best advantage
what hairstyle is correct for their particular
face the proper makeup and its application
many subjects which help create a better
appearance professional modeling courses are
also conducted for girls seeking a career in the
fashion world whether for personal satisfaction
or professional purposes such schools teach good
grooming habits to thousands of women each year
knowledge of personal care offered by experts
leads to an attractive appearance and personality
pioneer and leader in the scientific research of
human hair is react incorporated at saint paul
in fully equipped laboratories a
large staff of chemists and physicists
devote themselves to every phase of this research
developing and perfecting products used in beauty
salons all over the country for the care
of human hair modern science has told us
that hair differs structurally from
person to person so every known type
of hair is literally taken apart and
put together in these laboratories
the product development lab applies the
results of research to actual products
scientists test the quality and
action of every ingredient use
they discover if certain ingredients will blend
with other materials if they'll do exactly what
is required of them and various products are
tested for their resistance to harmful bacteria
to guard against skin irritation tests are made
on animals and if the results are satisfactory
a further test is made by patch testing human
beings the first patch testing is done on the
scientists who have prepared the formulas
men and women who are confident that when
a product has reached this point its safety
is well assured but testing doesn't stop here
the patch test wagon goes next to the
production floor where conscientious
employees display pride and pleasure
in their work by a willing response
to these vital tests by their personal
interest in the products they manufacture
finally a formula is selected but
it is not yet ready for manufacture
findings must undergo practical tests
in the experimental beauty salon
permanent wave lotions and hair colorings
are applied by professional beauticians
and exact comparisons are made with standard
products only when a formula meets all the
rigid standards which have been set up by
the company is it approved for production
raw materials for production come from every part
of the world lanolin from sheep's wool expensive
perfumes oil from the tropics and rare chemicals
this procurement is handled as carefully as the
research program specification of raw materials
must meet high standards when the raw materials
reach the warehouse quality control tests each
one and sample production runs are performed
once satisfied that all ingredients are of the
correct type the modern machines of the production
line take over turning quality raw materials
into quality beauty salon products in these days
of peak production and ever rising demand finished
products are rushed to the expanded shipping docks
where six to eight semiballers line up at once
for loading filled with permanent waves rinses
shampoos dandruff lotions hair colorings and
creams their cargos are the result of untiring
research loaded in saint paul they start on
their mission of beauty daily they travel
the highways carrying the tested products of
reyette incorporated to every part of the nation
saint paul lights are as fashion conscious as
folks in any of the big style centers of the
united states or europe we're a cosmopolitan
city in the midst of the great upper midwest
a place where well-dressed is a term taken
for granted where men and women consider their
appearance of utmost importance retail shops
in our town offer every member of the family
clothing that represents the very finest
tailoring and styling of the garment manufacturer
stocks are always plentiful with a wide
choice of apparel for every purpose
store owners and buyers maintain contact
with their customers their experience keeps
pace with and even anticipates our desires and
requirements when we enter a saint paul clothing
store to find a particular item we're seldom
disappointed because merchants do all they can to
display the newest line for every occasion showing
sponsored by both public and private organizations
keep saint paul women posted on new styles
and materials from the fashion capitals of
the world when these new clothes are released to
the public the women of our town will be among the
first to wear them through the conscientious
services of alert well-informed saint paul
retailers
in a town that boasts many tales of the romance
of industry the story of all breath furs and its
association with borgana the miracle man-made
fabric that looks more like fur than fur itself
is one that's caught and held the imagination
of folks of all ages in all walks of life
backed by a century of expert fur making the
company is well equipped to offer the women
of america the superior craftsmanship
the beauty and durability of borgana
when eris albrecht came to frontier st paul
in 1855 bringing with him the heritage of his
family's coburg germany fur business his dreams
of a wonderful new world could hardly have matched
the saint paul of today nor this modern store so
well known to discerning fashion conscious women
through the years the fur trade grew
an abundance of skins brought into st
paul by indian and white trappers gave skilled
furriers ample raw materials to cut and stitch
warm long-lasting coats coats to keep out
the cold of those long pioneer winters
fur wasn't a luxury in those days
it was a necessity for survival
fur coats were a common sight in an era
that saw mink pelts sold for a dollar apiece
just before the turn of the century america's
booming fur trade helped the company become the
largest manufacturing furrier in the west
otto albrecht the founder's son entered
the business in the 1890s and after assuming
the presidency originated the august for sale
now an annual institution in towns both
large and small throughout the united states
a nationwide mail-order clientele was also
developed and as fur requirements changed and
styles began to take on a new look every year
a skill and mastery of fur manufacture evolve
and was handed down from generation to
generation until today the showroom displays
the finest of the furrier's craft but in 1954
a revolution took place in the fur business
modern science and technology entered
the picture with something totally new
the miracle of borgana captured the imagination
of women from coast to coast when the george borg
corporation introduced its fur-like softness and
strength it's amazingly lightweight it's striking
beauty all made possible by the combination of
versatile man-made fibers for years furriers had
searched for an acceptable imitation fur many
attempts proved unsuccessful until george w
borg famed industrialist came up with borgana
the interest of president robert albrecht was
aroused and with the help of his chief designer
viola finland he became the first furrier to make
borgana coats an instant success production was
begun for nationwide selling from the initial
stages of manufacture albrechts treats borgana
with the same care as real fur folks who work
in the plant are actually trained furriers who've
worked with furs of all kinds from mouton to mink
after cutting coat parts the pattern the
pieces are carefully placed in stacks
all cutting is done by hand like fine first
each piece individually rather than several
layers at a time like cloth coats each piece
is meticulously color matched the same as fur
to assure an even consistent
color throughout the coat
every operation is performed under strict
supervision to maintain high standards
cutting finished and pieces assembled
they are ready for the sewing department
machines designed for stitching fur coats
are used exclusively in the sewing department
here too the skill gained from long experience
in the fur business determines the fine quality
found in these borgana coats pieces are accurately
guided through swift highly specialized machines
with one step finished the code
is passed on to the next operation
machine operators are all specialists
each trained in one sewing procedure
so that each part of the code receives
the very best workmanship possible
hands are indispensable in the
manufacture of a borgana coat
cape or stole style is an important factor
when women shop for a new winter coat
and since albrecht made borgana offers all
the qualities of workmanship found in the
most expensive fur coats it's only natural
that its style should be just as luxurious
the work of the cutters and machine operators
follows the specifications of designers
producing a coat that reflects the latest
in fashion trends a wide range of styles and
colors are available to fill the growing
demand and to satisfy every taste and
requirement
as the final operations are performed the results
of many skilled jobs are brought together in
a striking combination of an age-old craft and
the ingenuity and imagination of modern science
finished coats are given a thorough inspection
assuring quality of workmanship materials and
correct fit only garments conforming to the very
highest standards are permitted to leave the shops
capes stoles coats undergo the same
meticulous scrutiny before being shipped
to dealers from new york to california from
the canadian border to the gulf of mexico
the story of borgana is the story of american
industries efforts to provide people everywhere
with better products for better living through the
determination of scientific research to develop a
fabric with all the qualities of fine sheared fur
but with only a fraction of its weight and cost
and through the craftsmanship of all breck furs of
saint paul leading manufacturers of borgana coats
a clothing dream has become a reality
through the efforts of many people we
enjoy the best in clothing for this
is our town saint paul minnesota usa